[Risas]
[Música]
se han preguntado si están realmente
satisfechos con la vida que escogieron a
través de una carrera un trabajo o un
proyecto o tal vez si están estudiando o
trabajando por costumbre las
experiencias que tuve al irme a vivir a
méxico me invitaron a hacerme estas
mismas preguntas que hoy yo les hago a
ustedes estuve en méxico desde enero
hasta abril del 2020 cuando conseguí la
repatriación al ecuador por la crisis
sanitaria de kobe 19 si tal vez no fue
el mejor momento para irse de
intercambio pero son cosas que suelen
pasar bueno llevaba dos semanas
de haberme instalado cuando salí de la
zona en la que vivía
para conocer más de la ciudad tome el
tren con algunos amigos e inmediatamente
al salir de la estación tuve mi primer
encuentro real con la ciudad
pudo evidenciar una drástica segregación
urbana que en palabras de florencio
zoído es la acción o efecto de separar a
la población de una ciudad por motivos
socioeconómicos raciales o étnicos
pero tal vez ustedes se pregunten por
qué les hablo de que este es el primer
encuentro real con la ciudad porque la
realidad no es y no puede ser vivir en
una zona privilegiada como santafé
polanco la roma la realidad es que hay
personas que duermen en las calles por
ejemplo en el centro de la ciudad y hay
otras que pueden pagar departamentos de
800 mil dólares o más
y aquí les hago una pregunta les parece
conocido de alguna forma este contraste
seguro es porque latinoamérica entera
está asumido en la desigualdad
socioeconómica y tomando en cuenta lo
que dice el artículo 1 de la declaración
de los derechos humanos acerca de que
todos los seres humanos nacemos libres
e iguales en dignidad y derechos y el
artículo 2 que habla acerca de que todos
los seres humanos tenemos todos los
derechos y libertades sin distinción de
raza color sexo idioma origen nacional
origen social o posición económica en
latinoamérica vivimos en permanente
violación de los derechos humanos de
regreso en el metro recordé el dolor que
lleve conmigo desde el ecuador el dolor
y la ira de vivir en una sociedad
desigual de pobreza y racismo el
encuentro con estas realidades no hizo
más que reafirmar la necesidad de
concientizar sobre las problemáticas
sociales en nuestros países en
latinoamérica
y cuestionar nuestros privilegios de
clase y actuar frente a ellos un mes
después mientras estaba en clases las
noticias de informaron del femicidio de
ingrid escamilla cuatro años mayor que
yo y dos días después el de fátima de
apenas siete años era apenas una niña
ambas mexicanas las compañeras de la
universidad les organizaron un espacio
para conmemorar sus vidas y prometerles
luchar porque sus muertes no queden
impunes yo me uní silenciosamente esta
promesa mientras veía las fotos las
cartas de cariño los listones morados
las flores que les habían dejado no
podía evitar recordar a emilia benavides
de 10 años a juliana campoverde de 18 y
a tantas otras mujeres que perdieron la
vida por la misma causa un femicidio
todas asesinadas por hombres de sus
propios círculos sociales personas a las
que ellas les tenían confianza esta
cifra es
muy impresionante y es que en
latinoamérica una mujer es asesinada
cada dos horas por el solo hecho de ser
mujer entonces ustedes tal vez ya
entienden por qué en el 8 m en el 8 de
marzo yo sentí la necesidad de
manifestar me junto a mis hermanas de
ciudad de mexico en un boicot en el que
ninguna mujer fue a trabajar oa estudiar
para salir juntas a las calles y
reclamar a los estados por la
complicidad la impunidad que les
permiten a los agresores por el
asesinato y la desaparición de nuestras
hermanas y la ceguera de sus
instituciones tales del grado de
violencia machista que en plena
manifestación del 8 m o marzo del día de
la mujer
fuimos amenazadas varias veces con
ataques de ácido es importante
manifestar y contarles que en esta
marcha también estaban los familiares
las amigas
conocidos e incluso las sobrevivientes
de violencia de género pese al miedo que
trataron de infundir nos yo me encontré
ese día con mujeres unidas que se
abrazan y se cuidan compañeras que
luchamos por objetivos comunes cómo
acabar con la violencia de género más
adelante tuve la oportunidad de
conversar con un sobreviviente del
holocausto llamado branislau saber que
actualmente tiene 88 años quien a través
de su historia de reclusión a los 6 años
en la infancia
en el gueto de lódz polonia 1940 pudo
evidenciar el nivel y el extremo de
deshumanización y crueldad al que puede
llegar una persona con tal de conseguir
poder
el día en que brownie me contó su
historia no podía dejar de sentir tanta
incomodidad tanta ira y vergüenza porque
pese a que hablamos de los genocidios y
de las limpiezas étnicas como algo que
ya se hubiera acabado cuando se dio el
fin de la segunda guerra mundial son
cosas que siguen pasando en pleno siglo
20 y alrededor del mundo pese a que
existe la noción generalizada de que la
guerra y la violencia han decaído para
el siglo en el que vivimos
pensar en las experiencias de violencia
a través de las cuales tiene que
atravesar una persona un niño o una niña
para dejar la zona en la que vive dejar
su casa y dejar todo atrás
e irse a vivir a un campo de refugiados
o tener que moverse de un lugar para el
otro en busca de un sitio seguro no me
deja aceptar esta premisa como verdadera
esta premisa que fue y es sostenida por
steven ping más bien me invita a pensar
que lo que él señalaba se basa en el
privilegio de los ciudadanos de los
países llamados del primer mundo dude
mucho en contarles esta última
experiencia pero lo voy a hacer la
visita de mi novia en méxico coincide
con el fin de semana de cierre de
fronteras por la pandemia en ecuador así
que nos movilizamos desde las afueras de
la ciudad hasta el aeropuerto para
encontrar un boleto de regreso para él
cuando llegamos nos encontramos con un
ambiente total de caos todas las
personas corrían de un lugar para el
otro buscando una forma de regresar a
sus países
varios estados tomaron esta medida de
cerrar fronteras el ecuador no fue el
único país que hizo esto entonces si no
conseguían un vuelo en ese momento te
tenías que quedar
afuera de tu país cerca de dos meses o
más en la sala en la que estábamos
haciendo el trámite que es la que pueden
ver en las fotografías
nos encontramos con más ecuatorianos
habían niños sentados en el piso y otros
estudiantes para ponerlos en contexto yo
era la única estudiante ecuatoriana
de la universidad en la que estudia de
intercambio así que encontrarme con
ellos como ya se imaginan género en mi
mucha emoción y apego conversamos me
contaron sus historias
y no pude evitar pensar en que todos
tenían razones urgentes para regresar
una familia un trabajo muchos tickets
comprados con desesperación o el miedo
al mismo de contagiarse de esta
enfermedad que para aquel momento era
muy reciente como es el kobe 19 el
tiempo comenzó a pasar había muy pocas
respuestas y las personas comenzaron a
solicitar el apoyo y la intervención de
sus representantes en el exterior es
decir de miembros del cuerpo diplomático
ecuatoriano en méxico ellos estaban
enterados de lo que sucedía en el
aeropuerto y les habían enviado viáticos
sin embargo en nosotros había cierta
sensación de desconexión la
circunstancia en sí era muy compleja
estamos en una circunstancia de
desesperación y estrés por regresar a
nuestro país
y el no poder contar con un
representante que nos acompañe en este
proceso que nos explique qué estaba
pasando nos generaba este sentimiento de
desconexión reconozco y respeto el
trabajo de las y los diplomáticos
sé que hay varias cosas que están
haciendo desde su estructura sin embargo
a partir de esta experiencia me di
cuenta de que quería que mi forma de
luchar sea diferente todas estas
experiencias que les he contado a lo
largo de este télex configuran un punto
crítico en mi vida les voy a hacer
sincera y les voy a contar algo antes al
inicio de mi carrera yo estaba muy
emocionada y muy convencida de
especializarme y trabajar en diplomacia
estar presente en negociaciones
históricas y especialmente aunque suena
un poco difícil de decir o de admitir
construir una reputación y un estatus
para mí misma después de vivir todo
definitivamente no les puedo decir lo
mismo me decidí por un plan de vida en
el que mi objetivo central es la lucha
por los derechos humanos la lucha por la
igualdad de género en contacto y trabajo
directo con las personas
decidí que no quiero formar parte de eso
que te llama solamente a buscar tu
bienestar y ser cómplice silencioso de
las prácticas que perpetúan estas
relaciones de poder
mientras tú estás cómodo porque esa
realidad a ti no te toca preguntarnos a
nosotros mismos si estamos cómodos y
estamos satisfechos sobre todo con lo
que hacemos a diario las metas y
objetivos que nos hemos planteado y las
decisiones de vida que hemos tomado
comprendiendo que hay problemas y
asuntos más allá de nosotros más allá de
lo personal de lo que me pasa a mí como
la desigualdad social la pobreza la
violación de derechos humanos el
asesinato o la desaparición de una
persona por su género etnia orientación
política o creencia religiosa es algo
que tenemos que siempre tener en mente
despertar la conciencia social
cuestionarnos a nosotros mismos
eso es un proceso muy difícil es algo
complejo si el cuestionamiento nos hace
desmontar las verdades que hemos
construido a lo largo de nuestras vidas
como absolutas pero nos ayuda a forjar
planes más leales y comprometidos con
los procesos de transformación en
nuestras sociedades es así como comencé
mi proceso y cómo cómo comencé mi camino
en los derechos humanos cuestionando me
inicié un viaje que no esté exento de
dificultades es un trabajo de lucha
constante
y de ser valiente
sin embargo hay momentos que te empujan
a seguir luchando como el poder trabajar
con una ong y comprender que aún si se
habla de la construcción de la paz como
algo tan lejano algo un concepto utópico
a través de distintas líneas de trabajo
puedes ir resolviendo un problema a la
vez
e ir consiguiendo poco a poco este
objetivo
e implementar un proyecto de género en
la escuela a la que pertenezco y crear
la primera comisión de género en una
asociación de estudiantes de nuestra
universidad pero más importante conectar
con nuestras y nuestros compañeros en un
compartir de experiencias sentimientos e
ideas sobre la vida sentir el apoyo de
tantas hermanas para seguir trabajando
en colectivo y luchar por el
empoderamiento de las mujeres por sus
derechos y recibir la confianza de la
comunidad ted para contarles un poco de
mi historia hoy apenas estoy al comienzo
de este camino es verdad pero me motiva
el haber descubierto por dónde ir y
encontrar a más personas que como yo
están batallando contra los mismos
monstruos
es por ello que si nos vamos con algo de
esta charla te de c's es con la
necesidad de redefinir quiénes somos
como vemos al mundo y cómo actuamos
frente a esto si es necesario hacer una
lista con nuestros nuevos objetivos y
metas lo vamos a hacer con la esperanza
de contribuir a estos procesos activos
de transformación social gracias
[Aplausos]